bonsoir bonsoir alors les crise quelle
crise bah moi pour ce têt je vous
parlais d'une crise c'est une crise qui
dure depuis un siècle la crise des
question d'hérédité
parce que l'inné et l'acquis ça n'arrête
pas de poser des problèmes et c'est des
probables sont à la fois scientifique
mais aussi politique et idéologique
alors pour illustrer ça on va commencer
par un petit débat qui a eu lieu en 2007
entre sarkozy et michel onfray qu'un
philosophe de gauche comme vous le savez
ils sont inversés les positions sur la
photo alors donc on va regarder un petit
peu ce qu'ils racontent un moment ils en
viennent à dire qu' il va y avoir que où
il peut se dit parle de pourquoi ils en
tireront discute pas bien et on ferait
bien dire je pense que nous sommes
façonnés non pas par nos gènes mais par
notre environnement par les conditions
familiales et socio historique dans
lequel nous évoluons
c'est extraordinaire vous à un
politicien et un philosophe ils savent
tous les deux pas du tout ce que c'est
qu'un gène mais ils ont des idées dessus
et on ferait son idée c'est que les
gènes on s'en fout et ça c'est typique
de quelqu'un de gauche
et quand il ya quelqu'un dont on attend
face à tous les coups il va pas être
d'accord ça rate pas je suis pas
d'accord avec vous répond sarkozy jean
ferrat penser qu'on est bléneau fibre il
ya des jeunes qui se suicident en france
c'est pas parce que la france soit mal
occupé mais parce que génétiquement
envoyé lieu aussi ici que des il avait
une fragile nous leur préalable les
circonstances ne font pas tout la part
de l'idée est immense c'est éric dged
cette droite l'environnement ces couches
moi je suis généticien quand je fais une
manip je sais jamais à l'avant si je
vais trouver regrettable droite ou de
gauche
et ça m'angoisse alors je voulais à
attendez c'est pas là je vous dirais que
donc donc
donc voilà alors on va essayer de
comprendre un peu pourquoi ça et voir un
petit peu ce qui est possible de faire
alors le point de départ c'est darwin
comme presque tous en biologie darwin
qui se dit il ya des variations et la
sélection va sélectionner
enfin la section va favoriser certaines
variations et comme ces variations sont
irritables comme elles se transmettent à
la descendance et bah ça va permettre
d'expliquer l'évolution des espèces
bon d'accord mais alors comment ça
s'hérite c'est le cousin de darwin qui
s'appelle galton qui va développer les
statistiques pour comprendre toutes ces
questions et qui va dire que les
aptitudes intellectuelles des humains
son hérité de la même façon que leurs
caractéristiques physiques et il va en
profiter pour dire elle va tant qu'à
faire
ça vaudrait la peine de lancer une
nouvelle séance le gène ikke qui est
l'étude des méthodes sous contrôle
social qui améliore ou détériorant
l'égalité raciale des générations
futures
bon ça chaussée chauray alors le gène
ikke va effectivement démarré aux états
unis un dangereux au début du 20e siècle
elle est présentée comme un arbre ye qui
me convoque toutes les sciences donc
belle convergence pour prendre en main à
l'évolution humaine
on va partir d'idées relativement
délirante par exemple là vous avez un
gène qui se transmet dans une famille et
se gênent détermine la naissance hors
mariage les enfants illégitimes
voilà c'est un jet les grands journaux
de l'époque pour prendre la question
alors la légende noyant noir c'est
énorme au en rouge chez les débits unis
à l'asile en bleu c'est débile pas bien
l'asile bon vous avez deux dans un asile
il faut trois filles y en a une normale
est devenu bon pas de chance et puis
deux autres que t'es débile et qui ont
fait plein de débiles dans leur
descendance bon on peut pas continuer
comme ça et là effectivement la société
américaine va se préoccuper de ça les
états américains ont voté des lois
jeuniste au 1er janvier 1935 on entend
déjà à plus de 20000 stérilisation on
estime à 65 mille le nombre de gens
stérilisés pour cause de mauvais gènes
dans cette période aux états unis dans
les pays scandinaves et en a fait encore
plus quoi en suisse par elle à l'époque
on avait rien compris à la génétique bon
mais
et évidemment le champion du monde à
l'époque ça a été l'allemagne elle
mouillée c'est beau dessin d'un bel
allemand qui est écrasé par le poids des
débiles dans son pays et donc on va
s'occuper de ça et vous savez le
résultat c'est l'arrivée de décors de
concentration le low cost est donc c'est
cette horreur qui s'est produite en
allemagne contrairement à ce qu'on
raconte souvent france qui arrive et où
l'isolément
c'était le fruit d'un courant qui
portait plupart des pays occidentaux
donc c'est important et on voit déjà là
un petit peu la liaison entre les jeunes
et la droite alors ça hein ça l'est
d'autant plus fort que eux c'est
d'autant plus fort que du côté
soviétique alors c'était le contraire
on avait un très grand généticiens qui
s'appelait vavilov qu'ils aient un café
un travail remarquable sur la diversité
des plantes cultivées etc mais
malheureusement pour lui et bien un
aigrefin nommé lyssenko va apprendre le
pouvoir va faire comprendre à staline et
aux soviets que la génétique et une
chance réactionnaire contraire au
matérialisme historique pourquoi parce
que la génétique propre aux idées qui a
des différences à la naissance alors que
tous les mouvements ouvriers du début du
xxème siècle y compris le mouvement
marxiste étaient des mouvements qui
proposait ce qu'on appelait la tabula
rasa les hommes naissent tous semblables
et c'est seulement la société qui paie
différence en gros ce que racontait
offrait tout à l'heure alors le résultat
c'est que tous les généticiens
soviétiques vont être tués ils vont être
emprisonné et vavilov meurent de faim
par exemple en 1943 dans la prison de
saratov donc vous voyez d'ailleurs c'est
les derniers martyrs de la science à ma
connaissance et c'est pas une religion
qui les a tués c'est une autre idéologie
donc on en est là vous voyez que
effectivement la liaison gauche droite
et gêne l'environnement est très forte à
ce moment là et puis évidemment ça va
continuer pourtant dès le début les
généticiens avait pris en compte les
gènes et l'environnement
johan scène donc un grand savant danois
en études dans la diversité des tailles
de haricots par exemple il a vu que ça
serait parti c'est sur une belle courbe
normale on appelle ça et cette courbe
normale que oui à gauche et bien s'y
prend le haricot le plus grand ou le
plus petit est bien quand ils sèment des
descendants du plus grand et ben ils
trouvent des descendants plus grand que
le descendant du plus petit c'est ce que
oui à droite mais une fois qu'il a pris
5,3 les descendants du plus grand il
prend le plus grand et le plus grand le
plus petit il versait mais ce qu'il
obtient dans la descente c'est pas ça
change plus rien le fait de prendre le
plus petit ou le plus grand ça change
plus rien s'il fait ça à l'intérieur de
la descendance du plus grand ou à
l'internât naissance du plus petit et il
en déduit quoi il en déduit que aux
comptes au départ il
variations génétiques et les variations
environnementales que ce qu'ils voient
dans la deuxième partie de son
expérience de la différence génétique
c'est ce qui fait que les plus les
descendants des plus grands sont plus
grands que les descendants des plus
petits mais la différence
environnemental c'est ce qui fait que
les plus grands sont pas tous pareils
ils sont quand même une certaine
diversité et la ses universités qui est
pas due aux gènes mais à l'environnement
donc il ya les deux à il ya des gènes et
à l'environnement
bon mais alors combien pour chaque ça
c'est une drôle de question qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire sans mes
gènes qu'est ce que je ferais ou sans un
bon environnement mais évidemment c'est
impossible c'est pas ça la question
réalité j'ai essayé de trouver une
comparaison alors je vous propose celle
là dans un concours de sauts d'obstacles
qui est ce qui compte le plus c'est
chevalier le cavalier ou le cheval 1
alors à a priori on peut pas répondre et
du cavalier sans le cheval y fera rien
le cheval sans oublier non plus
probablement mais il ya des cas où on
peut répondre les cas où on peut
répondre c'est des concours spéciaux il
ya quatre cavaliers qui arrivent chacun
avec son cheval ils font le parcours et
après ils échangent de cheval et il
fonce à quatre fois au bout de quatre
fois ils ont tous essayé chaque cheval
et chaque cheval 6 et chaque cavalier et
si le résultat c'est celui que vous
voyez là c'est à dire c'est toujours le
même cavalier qui arrive en tête etc
elle va vous dites c'est le cavalier qui
décide du résultat si jamais vous
trouvez au contraire que c'est les
choses qui donnent tout bas vous dites
c'est les shows qui décide du résultat
dans la réalité ce que vous allez
trouver c'est des trucs dans ce genre là
bon alors là il faut faire des
statistiques je suis désolé mais
rassurez vous comme disait un ami
américain
les maths c'est comme l'amour on peut en
parler en public il faut pas le faire
devant tout le monde donc j'additionne
si je fais la somme par ligne de ses
résultats je vais trouver que la somme
pour les chevaux elle varie entre 8 et
12 alors que la somme pour les cavaliers
elle varie entre 5 et 15 eh bien je vois
que les cavaliers font plus de
variations que les chevaux voilà et je
vais dire qu'en ce cas là par exemple
que la variation est due à 70% aux
cavaliers son divorce 30% aux choux ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'
évidemment si jamais je change des
choses qui changent et camille je me
trouve autre chose ce n'est pas une
caractéristique générale c'est une
caractéristique de ce truc là quand je
dis le qi des enfants de francs français
dans les années 1960 et à 50% génétique
50% environnementale bas c'est vrai à ce
moment là pour ces enfants là ça serait
pas vrai ailleurs ça c'est des choses
qu'on sait faire
le malheur c'est que eh bien il ya
effectivement toujours de
l'environnement et toujours des gènes et
que la proportion de variations dues à
l'environnement aux jeunes dépend à
chaque fois de quelle expérience je fais
il ya rien de général là dedans
qui plus est je sais que chaque que
chaque gène peut avoir sans ces effets
changes et par l'environnement par
exemple il ya un gène qui fait que les
enfants peuvent pas digérer le lait ce
gène hla et il a aucun effet en france
actuellement parce que quand un enfant
naît si jamais on voit qu'il advienne là
on lui donne pas de l'est et du coup il
se porte très bien
alors que dans les pays où on sait pas
faire ça et bien les enfants en question
on détecte le produit n y voit du laid
sale empoisonne et y meurent donc
aujourd'hui ce truc là qui était
complètement déterminé par les jeunes
avant maintenant il est déterminé
vachement par l'environnement puisque
dans les pays où d'un bon système
médical les enfants sont pas malades
dans les pays où en un mauvais système
médical les enfants sont malades
autre exemple l'obésité il ya eu une
épidémie d'obésité on cherche pourquoi
les gens sur le buzz ou pas on trouve
des gènes d'obésité ces derniers ne
retrouve plus souvent chez les obèses
que chez nono bel et bien les gens qui
avaient des gens qui ont ces gènes
d'obésité ils ont siégé de l'âme et
leurs grands parents les avaient aussi
les grands parole ce n'est pas obèse ça
prouve que dans l'environnement d'avant
et ben saada ces jeunes n'avaient pas le
même effet qu'aujourd'hui
dernière exemple à un le sexe est bien
un exemple il est déterminé par des
gènes mais il ya plein de caractère qui
vont avec
par exemple dans cette salle je suis sûr
je potes on va bien voir mais je suis
sûr que globalement les gens qui ont un
chromosome y ont les cheveux plus courts
que les gens croient qu'on deux
chromosomes x 1c un effet du gène mais
voyez qu'il est très largement médiée
par l'environnement que si vous changez
l'environnement
si vous changez l'environnement
d'ailleurs quand j'étais jeune c'était
pas du tout comme ça croyez le ou pas
mais moi j'avais juste donc donc des
différences entre sexes sont médiée par
l'environnement et c'est pour ça qu'on
parle de genre pour parler des question
qui concerne le sexe mais qui sont liés
comment est-ce qu'on peut théoriser tout
ça est bien là l'hérédité vous voyez
qu'est ce que c'est que la vie la vie
c'est donc une information qui se
transmet à travers les organismes une
information génétique et cette
information a été postulé par donc donc
dès le début du xxème siècle un nom
pareil je vais faire tout de suite
choisi guerre bien sûr et donc l'ati
l'avait bon si ça peut vous rassurer
monticule procès des protéines mais
l'idée était bonne
et effectivement il ya une information
qui est codé alors est ce qu'on peut
dire que les gènes produits qu'est ce
que c'est qu'une information d'abord
elle est portée par un support matériel
mais elle n'est pas réductible à support
matériel parce que je peux la recopier
sur un autre support 1 par exemple je
peux sotoco enfin je peux la photocopie
une feuille de papier mais je peux aussi
l'as cannes et la passer dans un
ordinateur on peut lire une information
et cette information elle va pouvoir
donner une action grâce à un système de
lecture et tout ça va se produire dans
un environnement donné
regardez voilà deux d'information un
l'information elle même et les amorphe
on n'a jamais vu un livre se mettre à
le bazar dans une société en lui
même mais appartement où les hommes ne
lisent à ce moment là le livre il a un
effet non pas par lui-même mais par le
fait que les hommes sont des systèmes de
lecture qui change c'est donc
donc est ce qu'on peut dire que les
jeunes produisent des protéines non les
jeunes ils font rien ou ne pas plus que
les que les bouquins simplement il ya un
système qui lie les gènes dire que un
gène produire des protéines ça parle que
de dire qu'une recette de tarte aux
pommes produites tarte aux pommes c'est
idiot n'est ce pas une tarte aux pommes
ces produits par un cuisinier
mais il sert de la recette est dans une
cuisine donné bon et c'est ça qui va
faire la génétique c'est pareil vous
avez une information génétique codé sur
l'adn vous avez tout un système de
lecture qui va lire cet adn qui va avec
ça avec un code donné bien fabriquer
progressivement un oeuf va se
transformer en un embryon qui va se
développer et l'embryon elle va
continuer voyez vous aviez c'est être là
quand vous étiez petits et même celle là
je suis désolé pour lui et donc et à la
fin ça donne vous voilà et tout ça donc
dans un environnement donné
il ya donc trois éléments adam
l'hérédité la génétique
le système de lecture lecture c'est sale
épigénétique
et puis l'environnement alors tous les
systèmes informatiques informatifs sont
comme ça vous avez un message un
décodeur un environnement dans le cas de
la tarte aux pommes
la recette le cuisinier la cuisine dans
le cas à un autre cas que j'aime bien
c'est la musique
une partition un interprète un lieu dans
lequel ça se passe est évidemment le
lieu aussi important
et dans le cas d'un organisme vivant le
génome l'organisme le milieu à chaque
fois donc et voyez donc trois science la
génétique l'épigénétique l'environnement
et les trois doigts font fabrique
organisme j'aime bien la métaphore
musicale parce que quand on entend jouer
de la musique un violoniste qui joue de
la musique et bien il va effectivement
avoir à prendre des décisions quand il
commence une phrase musicale il peut
commencer avec la pointe de la recherche
est ce qu'on arrive à pousser où il peut
commencer que le talent on arrive à
tirer et sur une partition est bien le
violoniste va marquer avec des petits
singh voyez le sync le tuning sont
marqués en rouge
il va marquer s'il commence avec le
talon ou s'il commence avec la pointe de
manière à savoir comment il veut le
faire et surtout s'ils sont plusieurs il
faut qu'ils fassent tous pareils donc
c'est très important de faire ça de
noter ça simplement ça on le marque au
crayon sur la partition parce que la
fourchette fois on pourra très bien
faire autre chose eh bien je vais vous
dire que les pies génétique ça marche
pas mal comme ça donc vous avez compris
un peu oui ça change pas la partition
sachant juste la façon dont on va la
lire et bien l'épigénétique et un truc
pareil
vous avez un petit titre comme chimiques
qui s'appelle un radical méthyle bon
c'est un carbone avec 3 hydrogène qui
peut se coller comme ça ça spécial e3
qui peut se coller n'importe où parce
qu'il reste une valence libre
et il va se coller sur les sucres qui
forte de support de l'adn et quand ils
se cognent voyez il peut se coller ou
pas sur ce truc là ça fait des petits
points bleus sur l'adn ça va changer la
façon dont le système de lecture lille
adn
et quand on va recopier l'adn évadés
fois ces petites structures vont rester
dans la forme recopier des fois ils n'y
seront pas et donc on va pouvoir avoir
une manière de lire l'adn qui sera
marqué mais qui pourra être ou non
maintenue au cours du temps où c'est ça
c'est une des formes de l'épigénétique
alors ça c'est important parce que tout
ça ça veut dire que pour comprendre bien
commencé avec un organisme il faut
comprendre
l'épigénétique et donc c'est tout un
programme de recherche afin de se
développer à fond combien de temps
est-ce que les informations peuvent
perdurer ou pas est-ce que ça mais trop
copié bon on sait qu'il ya des cas à des
stress par exemple chez des humains qui
donne encore des résultats trois
générations après un bon qu'on sait que
ça existe
et puis c'est ta façon ludique est ce
qu'elle peut influer sur l'information
génétique
évidemment en changeant l'expression
elle va pas changer de l'information
elle même mère changera l'expression
elle peut changer la façon dont elle est
sélectionnée par exemple et enfin
quelles sont les relations entre
l'information épigénétiques et puis
l'environnement l'environnement par
exemple pour un bébé qui dans sa mère
est basque
on considère que la mer c'est
l'environnement ou est ce qu'on
considère que la merci de l'épigénétique
bon ça c'est des détails la réalité mais
comprenez bien une chose c'est que ce
tout ce travail de recherche qui est en
train d'être faits est un peu compliquée
par le fait que derrière il ya tous les
preuve d'idéologie dont je vous ai parlé
au début il ya tellement de gens qui
aimeraient se débarrasser des jeunes qui
voient l'épigénétique comme la sainte
vierge qui va enfin les débarrasser de
la génétique
vous comprenez ça veut dire que et bien
on va pouvoir rendre l'hérédité plus
réversible
ça fait tellement plaisir plutôt qu'un
truc qui change pas un
et puis re donner la primauté moi je
suis un individu je suis pas content que
mes génies se démerdent sans moi je
voudrais avoir la primauté sur ballack
l'épigénétique je peux espérer la voir
donc le plat difficulté c'est que les
scientifiques parfois c'était humains
ils sont tous nous sommes tous liés à
notre idéologie et cette idéologie et
bien nous faire conduit parfois
peut-être à dire des conneries je
remercie chars optima dessinée ça sur un
coin de table à jour aujourd'hui porter
en honneur
pour finir cet exposé je vous remercie